[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's more
than just a flash in the pan and in this
video we're breaking down the first look
at the flash the brand new teaser
trailer for the movie was unveiled at dc
fandom this weekend and it's packed with
easter eggs hidden details and also
things you missed there's also some big
clues towards who the true villain of
the piece is and we have a lot of wild
theories about what's really going on
now the trailer opens with what is a
shot of wayne manor from the original
batman 1989 movie by tim burton
accompanying this are the opening notes
of the song photos slash beautiful
dreamer from the original danny elfman
soundtrack
[Music]
wayne manor still carries across a lot
of the iconography from the 1989 film
including the gate that was in it and
there are also gargoyles which two
featured in that movie a vast blanket of
fog also surrounds the location and adds
so much more to the mystique of the
movie now the film will be pulling
across elements of flashpoint which is
pretty much the graphic novel that kicks
started the new 52 in it barry allen
traveled back in time and stopped his
mother from being murdered which had
massive ramifications for the universe
it's in a shock way through time and
this affected a lot of the events in the
universe bruce wayne was shot in the
alleyway instead of his parents and
because of this his father became batman
and his mother became the joker superman
also didn't crash land in smallville and
he was taken in by the government who
experimented on him and kept him locked
in a prison away from the sun because
the justice league was never formed
wonder woman and aquaman's kingdoms both
went to war and it led to the world
being completely wiped out in the final
few scenes which made barry travel back
in time once more to make sure that his
mother was murdered happy mother's day
now just in the same way that the new 52
was used to rewrite the dc cannon i feel
like this movie is going to be somewhat
of a soft reboot and it'll keep certain
elements in place whilst getting rid of
others it was said in reports last year
that keaton would be a nick fury type
figure so they might keep him doing that
in the main universe whilst pattinson is
off in his own i'd love to see ben
affleck return and get a snide of her
spin-off in its own continuity too and
we know from behind the scenes looks
that he will be in this film as well now
the trailer seems to be changing things
up slightly and instead of there being
superman we now have supergirl remember
in flashpoint superman was weakened on
purpose and it looks at one point that
supergirl is two as barry nurses over
here potentially it could be the same
thing here but we'll just have to wait
and see now the batman still seems to be
bruce wayne and he will be played by
michael keaton interestingly there's two
versions of barry allen but i actually
have a theory that this is the reverse
flash in flashpoint we discover that the
reverse flash was stalking barry through
time and mocking him as he just messed
up the entire timeline now in the comics
reverse flash traveled back in time to
kill barry but he killed his mother
instead his father was framed for it and
it just ripped the allen household apart
initially barry thought it was him who
had changed the timeline but as we
learned towards the end of the book it
was barry saving his mother that it
caused the fallout still low he hung
around just having a laugh and showed up
like a trench coat flasher to expose the
true plan flasher thank you now i
actually believe that the second barry
we see in the film will be the reverse
flash and it's not barry allen from
another timeline the reverse flash's
colours are yellow and in the trailer we
can see that the character wears these
throughout bit of a tenuous link but
we'll get into it now we see the two
barrys arrive on the grounds of wayne
manor in a taxi which has a license
plate that reads central city this is
the home of the flash in the comics and
it's clear that they've traveled a long
way to get there in the comic book barry
traveled to batman because batman would
know what to do but he found a very
different one to what he was expecting
clearly the two have met up and this
wouldn't be the first time that the
flash has come face to face with another
version as ezra miller and grant gustin
did in the cw special crisis on infinite
earths coming face to face with himself
in the crossover might have sparked up
the idea that he should go and see if
there were alternate versions of himself
which would lead into this movie see
it's all it's all connected guys keep
saying that now shout out to my superior
version from the multiverse ryanairy who
spotted that the top of the taxi has the
cab number 163 which is the issue in
which barry first met the reverse flash
they head inside the manor and this is
our first look at the inside there's a
grand staircase and also lots of things
covered in dust cloths which i'm
guessing confirms that alfred is dead
bruce wayne never had to clean up so he
probably has no idea what to do and the
mansion itself is becoming very run down
over the top of these clips we hear
michael keaton narrating the fact that
barry can go to any timeline and any
universe but he wants to know why he
wants to stay and fight to save this one
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
well this is clearly because of it being
the one in which his mother is still
alive barry wants to do nothing more
than have a relationship with her as it
not only means that he gets a normal
life but his dad also doesn't go to
prison for the rest of his now in the
trailer we see him traveling back to his
home at night and we can catch the
number 12 on a mailbox in the daytime
shot he walks up to the front door and
we can also see the number 12 confirming
that this is the same house this thing
cuts to him coming across his mother in
the kitchen i actually think that this
is a cut up of the end of the movie and
potentially also the start in flashpoint
we don't actually see barry travelling
back in time to save her until the big
reveal at the end when he learns that
this was the event in which he killed
her before resetting the timeline barry
travels back to his mother and tells her
everything and the pair have a really
emotional farewell it's absolutely
heartbreaking and kevin smith cried over
this for about three hours she's hanging
i'm not crying mine i'm not crying now
why i think this is at the end of the
movie is because flash has a brand new
suit in it that we later seen wearing in
the cave it just makes sense to me that
he works towards this gets it and then
goes back to see his mother even the
bhuta golden and grant gustin would be
proud now if you're enjoying the video
we'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
now i think that he will arrive at the
house and then remember him traveling
back in time to save her this will then
lead to him telling her that she's gonna
have to die so that things can go back
to normal and it's no doubt going to be
a very messed up scene other moments of
note in this are barry starting up the
power in the bat cave which has the same
sound effect and spark up that was shown
in the burton films we then see barry's
hand i think this is the one with the
longer hair due to the jacket he's
reaching out and touching an elderly
person's one who seems to be collapsed
in the bat cave i'm guessing they're
coming across keaton here who's passed
out on the floor we then hear bruce
saying he's changed the future and the
past we then get some shots of the
batsuit with a cowl removed and around
it are small pools of blood i have seen
a lot of people on twitter saying that
this could be affleck's cowl and that it
even looks like a cross between keaton's
and his there's some really nice
theories about him potentially melding
the two together but after looking at it
a lot i think it's just keaton's
keaton's batsu can also be seen in the
background and this definitely just
seems like it's something bruce took off
and dropped on the floor after a tough
night the character does something
similar in the dark knight returns after
going toe-to-toe with the mutant leader
and he returns to the bat cave and takes
the armor off dumping it on the floor as
he retreats further into the darkness
interestingly this suit pops up again
later on in the trailer and we can see
the second barry wearing it andy
muscetti dropped a post on instagram
recently showing the flash symbol spray
painting over the top of the bat one and
it looks like this is definitely what's
happened here you also see at one point
the bat boots getting a flash symbol
spray paint on them so that just makes a
lot of sense to me now barry's costume
is typically kept within a flash ring
and this can be seen in the trailer
though we don't get much of it we can
also catch supergirl here at this point
so i'm guessing that this is towards the
end of the film before barry goes back
in time it's just the two barrys who
arrive at the mana and if we follow
flashpoint then they rescue superman and
return here though he isn't with them in
the book potentially they went off and
got supergirl and then came back to send
barry back into the past we do get an
image of barry in a weird room at some
point staring at a statue and i actually
think that this might house the cosmic
treadmill which has been shown in toys
though the setup is slightly different
this was used to send barry back further
into the past than he'd ever been before
so it makes a lot of sense that it would
pop up here now in zack snyder's justice
league very reverse time but it was only
a couple of seconds so the treadmill
would help him to go back further i
almost wonder if this is something that
the ben affleck version helped him to
build in order to send him back into the
past i'm not sure if we'll ever see the
nightmare timeline again but i think an
amazing way to start the movie would be
to have us pick up immediately after
zack snyder's justice league with the
group all running back to the bat cave
whilst an evil superman tries to kill
them they get there and then barry runs
back to the past gives the warning to
bruce and batman v superman and then
continues through time and ends up back
at his house i know that's not really
the original plan that zack snyder had
but it would somewhat help to give at
least resolution to the nightmare
timeline and i'd much rather it was
acknowledged than completely ignored the
world being destroyed would be a good
reason for someone to go back in time
and yeah that's just personally what i
like to see now the batcave also has a
back computer in it and a landing deck
for what i'm guessing is the batwing
there's also a waterfall which wasn't
present in the original design as batman
drove through a fake cave entrance this
makes it look like the one that bale had
and this may not even be the original 89
universe but rather a similar offshoot
to it right after this we get our first
look at the new suit and we can see that
barry is indeed wearing it michael
keaton's cowl comes in two but it also
looks slightly like the bail batman
begins one from behind we get somewhat
of the hands in the drums so i'd
absolutely love it if this was the bale
version as well and we just had no idea
now that's just a crazy theory but
listen to the clip again with that in
mind
now that's probably pretty unlikely but
it would just be so cool if they did it
the other music isn't exactly the same
it sounds way more like the zimmer stuff
than anything that elfman put out the
bat cave looks way closer to the version
that was in the nolan movies and even
just a cameo would make this one of the
biggest surprises in a comic book movie
ever now the trailer ends with barry
asking someone if they're in i think
that this is obviously bruce wayne due
to the dump uniform and stuff it may
even be that he's retired and they're
going back to the bat cave to ask for
him to come back we then get the logo
which has a maze-like structure to it
and kurt debarry about to pull the top
off the top of the batmobile now i have
seen leaked images for the film and if
they're legit which i think they are
then this is the 1989 anton first one we
can't show them in this video because of
copyright reasons but you can tell by
the shape of the cloth that it is indeed
the same one now if this is the reverse
flash then his reaction makes sense as
well as the villain was obsessed with
superheroes and also history him seeing
this would absolutely blow his mind and
it makes sense why he's so curious about
it also tell ezra miller that he has a
really nice choker hey i said choker not
choker
anyway that's me getting cancelled and
also the end of the trailer breakdown
bit now as with my thoughts on it i
absolutely loved the first look and for
me it was the second best thing at dc
fandom after the batman trailer the
event did have a lot of filler i think
but this was something that was worth
sitting through it for as though it was
short it gave us a lot of ideas over
what was going to be happening in the
film i really think that keaton is
someone who's a massive get for the
studio and seeing him back in the cowl
will be an absolutely outstanding moment
that will pretty much make fans go
completely wild for it the multiverse
offers up a lot of things for the future
and also gives dc the chance to kind of
correct the course and get things all in
place so that the universe and the
mistakes of it are brushed to the side i
actually kind of respect that marvel
spent 10 plus years carefully building
up towards the multiverse and then dc
just completely screwed things up and
said [ __ ] it multiverse it is either way
if it leads to movies like this then i
really don't mind as it's such a cool
concept what they have here is the
opportunity to not only fix the universe
but also bring back some beloved fan
favorites and get us to see the
emotional heartbreak that barry had to
go through in losing his mother being a
hero is of course about sacrifice and
having to give up what you love the most
which i think this story can embody all
of the heroes look like they're kind of
on the back foot here i think it's gonna
make for a really interesting plot i
know amongst the comic book movie
community that there's people who love
ezra and others that are a bit unsure on
his portrayal but this movie feels like
it has enough going on that anyone will
find something to love you of course
have keaton ben affleck's batman and
also supergirl as well as the flash so
there really is a reason for everyone to
go and see it it's super small by warner
brothers to do this and hopefully it
pays off as this has the potential to be
a massive multiverse movie i think the
batman is still my number one from the
event by quite a bit but this was an
awesome trailer that i'm really really
excited for either way i really enjoyed
the teaser and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you have a
theory or we missed something then i'd
love to hear it as there's definitely a
lot to talk about we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase 3 mcu boxer on
the 30th of october and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the batman trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we gave a first look reaction to it and
pointed out a lot of the easter eggs
that we found so definitely go and watch
it right after this without the way
thank you for singing through the video
i've been paul and i'll see you on the
next one you take care peace